[Musique]
dans les boppois rôle annonce l'union
à la peine
[Musique]
monet
kadhafi je veux prendre au jeu léché les
gosses
oui vous le dire à peu près quand a été
créé le premier marché à paris il faut
remonter quand même assez loin pour
trouver la date exacte mais voilà 900
verts dans les 960 de haut mais si nous
voulions remontée alors à ce moment-là
plus loin dans les temps le négoce des
commerçants se faisait déjà parler les
gens qui venaient vendent les produits
venant des bateaux savez des produits
des épices débarquer à marseille et qui
suivait toutes les grandes voies pour
aller ravitailler les villes
dans le temps les marchés existait dans
les rues de paris puisque les gens en
vendait sur des échoppes où même dans
les rues de paris mais malheureusement
ça ne donnait pas satisfaction à tout le
monde parce qu'on parlait déjà aussi à
cette époque là des embarras de
circulation
c'est pas le prix d'une passion et puis
dans 15 jours c'est l'autre qui va en
découler
et attention petit bain je fumais pas
celui là
tout comme j'étais mais ça il faut
remettre parce que contre sa tâche mais
on met ça l'a tué pour la présentation
je suis monsieur lapierre secrétaire
général de la fédération nationale des
commerçants non sédentaires et
présidents des syndicats de montreuil de
la bande us et de la porte de montreuil
est ce que les marchés tend à
disparaître
au contraire le grand souk nos marchés
sont toujours très vivant du reste par
le dynamisme de nos commerçants et puis
la sympathie que les clients nous
accordent pour nous faire confiance dans
le maintien de marché via une sorte de
marché y est ils ont il ya toutes sortes
de marchés il ya des marchés
alimentaires il ya des marchés
d'articles manufacturés il ya des
marchés de brocante
il y à des marchés 2
bonneterie tous les tous les articles on
peut trouver de tout sur les marchés de
tout ce qui peut exister au point de vue
commercial il ya aussi de très grands
marchés de temps des campagnes des
marchés de bestiaux où l'on voit encore
des gens venir vendre aussi des petites
volaille sur les marchés des produits de
la ferme même et via aussi énormément de
petits producteurs qui vendent les
produits de leurs cultures ou même des
aviculteurs toutes sortes de métiers
tout ce qui est négociable se vend sur
nos foires et marchés
on les marchés ambulants ne n'ont pas
tendance à disparaître loin de là nous
avons deux précédents à sarcelles
récemment les ménagères avait avait
plusieurs supermarchés elles ont elles
même demandé alors maire de créer un
marché justement un marché découvert et
nous avait moins un autre précédent dans
le 15e arrondissement un marché viennent
s'y créent rhubarbe
ce marché va s'appeler le marché
cervantes il va démarrer exactement dans
trois semaines
archer découvert également
[Musique]
les marchés sont créés depuis maintenant
plus d'un siècle nous avons 52 marchés
découvert à paris et jusqu'à maintenant
aucun accord n'a disparu et malgré tout
la relève se fait avec les jeunes vous
faites ce métier depuis combien de temps
depuis plusieurs générations depuis mon
arrière grand mère ma grand mère mes
parents et moi même
nous avons nous en tous les marchés de
paris et nous avons comme un grand mère
a commencé à faire paris versailles avec
une hotte sur le dos ensuite avec des
chevaux maintenant avec des voitures
enfin c'est le progrès
mais
là
le marché de gros a lieu vers une heure
du matin ils attirent les commerçants
arrive de réglisse et en même temps il
ya les commerçants dès le sommet des
agriculteurs les producteurs bourguibien
en même temps les agriculteurs il n'a
presque plus grand étant donné qu'ils
ont été belles sa expropriait quoi il
convient cinq ou six mois maintenant
oui cette terre de première qualité est
excellente à travailler les jeunes seuls
les plus j'ai pissenlit madame pourquoi
pour la vente au marché
où ça à versailles vous avez des places
depuis combien d'années quand depuis
sept ans à peu près vous aimez ce que
vous faites
oui
il ya des gens qui achètent pas beaucoup
il ya des gens qui achètent beaucoup
pour avoir le contact avec vous
justement portant les avec vous pour
raconter leurs petites misères à ses
portraits drôles
quelquefois il pleure ma vie mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait on n'essaie plus ou moins
des remontées mais c'est toujours pareil
c'est difficile surtout dans vis-à-vis
moi je suis de l'autre côté du banc il
n'y a pas de problème j'essaie de leur
remonter le moral mais il ya des fois
c'est difficile
finalement le marché c'est vrai que
c'est ainsi c'est une grande famille je
pense
que faites vous monsieur je suis en
train de débarquer les mettra de manière
à les laver ensuite seront variés et les
faire cuire combien on en met un matelas
jeu mais 70 kg betteraves cuites
une fois cuites il y en a 70 kg et a
longtemps vous cultiver cette terre oui
un douzaine d'années vous aimez votre
métier j'adore mon métier mais
malheureusement je crois que ça va ça va
se terminer
pourquoi parce que non expropriations et
puis enfin faut se replacer à iris pas
facile à trouver
on avait juste un passage
[Musique]
mais il ya encore des maraîchers com
enfin il y en a beaucoup moins maillot
bien il ya sept ans que je fais
versailles nous étions je prends dix ou
douze ma richesse il en reste quatre
cinq peut-être va faire le gros le matin
et puis enfin il veut ils sont tous se
disent avoir le détail disons consentir
davantage quoi
c'était hier que les enfants ne reprenez
pas c'était beaucoup d'anciens qu'ils
ont comme les dents entreprenez pas
derrière ces sas père
j'ai cherché cherché là je suis verdict
vous faites aussi des légumes oui madame
qu'est-ce que vous utilisez et bien les
poireaux les carottes les rades il les
tue la scarole des épinards mais ça fait
combien de temps vont bien et moi depuis
tout le temps j'ai pris la suite de mon
père s'habiller et bien j'ai 45 ans
alors je disons qu'à la sortie de
l'école ça fait combien 21 ans
vous aimez votre métier oui oui au
départ non et puis oui maintenant j'en
suis bien content
ok
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'avant dit que vendez-vous marché et
bien les oeufs et comment ils le cycle
alors eh bien nous achetons les poussins
1 jour vous en acheter environ 3000 qui
reste dans un petit poulailler mois et
demi deux mois nous les sépareront les
divise en deux et vers quatre mois et
demi cinq mois nous les mettons dans un
corps plus grand poulailler en cage
il reste combien de poule à ce moment là
haut ou très peu de pertes 2008 170
alors c'est cool bondir mme yade par
jour parce que pas toujours un seul mais
pas des bébés avaient ça fait combien
d'heures par jour
en tout dans les 2300 2400 plein ponte
dans les dix-huit sont en pente faible
alors vous allez au marché comme une
fois par semaine à versailles trois fois
hélas vous en rendez combien chaque fois
à peu près chaque fois 2 en moyenne 3000
5 a fait mille quelquefois plus 5000
enfin la moyenne 4000 vous fait ce
métier plus combien de temps 22 ans
vous aimez ces titres qu'est ce que vous
faites c'est très agréable
ce que je faisais avant de mariée
j'étais étudiante aux beaux-arts mais il
ya un grand changement a dit combien ça
ne fait rien j'étais heureuse oui j'y
serai qu'est ce qui vous plaît le plus
la fille à la campagne la nature tout
simplement la vraie vie la vérité et
vous êtes aidez pour nourrir toutes ces
poules
tout se fait automatiquement
et pour vous c'est quoi le marché s'est
un peu tout à la fois c'est toute ma vie
c'est une fête c'est un travail c'est
une joie c'est c'est tout c'est toute ma
vie
[Applaudissements]
et merci bien pour l'avoir maintenant
les premiers jugements des dernières
soixante 60 ans 60 ans et l'âge n'ont
pas ici makoun produit du conduit de
miel à congrès musulman pour plus de 18
ans c'est votre miel avec mes parents
étaient piqués le seul aussi à ce moment
là j'avais une trentaine de ruches et
maintenant on va maintenant on les a ni
davantage
j'y monte un champ seulement maintenant
baisse parce que je suis 3g mois à
présent j'en ai une cinquantaine et vous
aimez votre métier a beaucoup madame
avec le sourire mais quand j'étais plus
jeune mois et autrefois quand j'allais
recours on allait on était en pleine
campagne coens dans la nièvre
nous on est dans le cher et je
conduisais une conduite avec un cheval
on me dit 4h30 vous y allez 4 et les
niveaux entiers et hongres de son mieux
là bas sur la place de coûts vous
n'allez jamais réagissent à non non non
jamais vous êtes grossistes et les
marchands forains venus alimenter ici
s'approvisionner ici
oui tous les jours de paris de paris de
la banlieue et nous avons même des
clients de
deux provinces qui viennent s'alimenter
ici sur le marché de rungis dans la gare
ou alors ça fait quand même occasion on
vantait le froid mais enfin le maintien
au moins bien moi je laisse un petit
plateau lequel diminue un peu ça va
arriver sur montreux pour la mairie
qualité club et ils sont arrivés bon et
qu'on artichauts là il est bon signe
l'artichaut l'artichaut sont 80 là
dedans on arrive à une dizaine de colis
aux différents si tu veux mais en plus
parce que c'est des ajustements
ballantyne en a une dizaine de colis oui
d'accord
alors comme d'habitude oui eh ben dis
donc le congo sous préfète
willow il est petit mais enfin il est
fort bien c'est les 35 85 22 c dans
l'enfer l'a26 franco lee 5 et 25 quads
monstres non pardon messieurs je t'ai
fait lorsqu'il merci ben on fait tous
les marchés de paris là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis à ménilmontant
demain je vais faire le cours de
vincennes enfin nous avons démarché tous
les jours
[Musique]
merci
la vente commence vers 10h30 et se
termine vers 2h30 3h de l'après midi et
les parrains les forains viennent un
petit peu plus tard étant donné qu'ils
n'ont pas les mêmes problèmes que les
détaillants de cours des halles ou que
les grossistes de province ou que les
demi grossistes les détaillants des
problèmes de remballage il faut qu'ils
remballent leurs marchés avant de venir
ce qui fait qu'ils arrivent un petit peu
plus tard sur le marché
on est obligé d'acheter dans l'après
midi
achetez l'après-midi pour revendre le
lendemain alors ça aussi c'est anormal
pas sur la marchandise allait
complètement pourri le lendemain encore
aujourd'hui ça va s'il fait frais mais
quand elle va arriver là
le premier soleil on aurait pu le radier
on aura plus de concombres on aura plus
de lyon n'aura plus frais la france a
sera tourné parce qu'on l'achète l'après
midi ça sera de marchandises de 48
heures ça aussi c'est anormal
par exemple cela aujourd'hui bon bah ils
sont obligés d'acheter ils sont obligés
de se prendre trois jours d'avant c'est
à dire que leur a dit qu'on l'achète
aujourd'hui on emmagasine dans un coin
on leur vend jusqu'à dimanche pour moi
ça va pas trop cher alors sa déroute à
deux débats et dans l'artichaut ont été
matés un peu partout sur la place
de prendre 60 23 noms 24 si tu savais
tout cas moi j'ai toujours fait les
marchés on a c'est plus facile
maintenant on essaie pour les épiciers
on n'est plus des marchands de fruits et
légumes primeurs attention c'est plus
pareil si on essaye de faire quelque
chose mais personne ne nous écoute
vous voyez de 10 rebonds les halles la
nuit mais veulent plus travailler la
nuit wall a le temps de se préparer le
temps d'arriver moi je me lève tous les
jours à 3h ici à 5 heures il faut aller
se dépêcher bon ça va parce que son mari
va aux halles avant et peuvent aller
manger mais moi je n'ai pas le temps
d'aller manger et c'est tous les jours
comme ça je me trompe personne ici va
manger on n'a pas le temps ne peut pas
on a besoin d'un repas aussi trois repas
par jour c'est tout à fait légal c'est
tout à fait normal et most-hid victoires
quatre ans
comment 4,30 tard on allait les papes et
commettant deux
[Applaudissements]
un homme est en de bonnes mains pour le
barça tu me saigne oh oui oh ouais tu
monde afrique en bout les quatre alors
évidemment je faisais un petit prix et
vous venez souvent ici tous les jours
madame tous les jours j'avais on a pas
mal de travail sur nos marchés pour les
achalandé et on est obligé de descendre
tous les jours bien entendu les horaires
ne correspondent pas tout à fait à nos
désirs mais on se contente de ce qu'on
vous ai dit si quelqu'un d'autre est là
je me suis dépêché aujourd'hui puisque
j'ai dû pas mal de travail à faire du
tri et ma femme est ta bon ben là notre
problème est que en allant régissent le
vendredi on a 25 % de hausse par rapport
aux jours normaux alors ça c'est anormal
alors ils viennent me téléphoner à
l'instant pour acheter justement qu'on
vendredi samedi et dimanche dont trois
meilleurs joueurs du marché il est
écoeuré par ce que tout est beaucoup
tout ce que ce que je vois aujourd'hui
c'est le prix des halles
en ce moment ça fait combien bull car tu
sais le prix 4,50
n'est ce pas non je dédicace a alors
fait coûte moins un petit bichon
nous voulons vous dire
ecoute-moi viendra
gage de plus
4 36e mais 90 4 temps brumeux avec les
mots peut dire c'est vrai qu'à 30
quatre bombes atomiques à l'angop
familles seront du voyage te fait
plaisir
la prochaine fois ces policiers
chacun son tour vachon et puis on peut
plus travailler non plus vite et ça avec
clients qui viennent de partir et c'est
bien dommage parce que elle elle s'était
passé pas après les halles qu'elles ont
annoncé après nous parce qu'on a à faire
carrément le consommateur est ce que
vous avez beaucoup de forains qui
viennent vous acheter ils achètent peu à
la fois tout cela ça dépend de
l'importance sur les marchés qui vous
avez affaire à des clients qui
travaillent en famille par exemple père
ou la mère videmment l'achat et moins
moins important par contre si vous avez
encore un qui a sept ou huit employés
les quantités sont beaucoup plus
importantes
nous on ne peuvent pas pour quand on met
arrive là bas les horaires au lieu
d'ouvrir à une heure comme comme celles
prescrites dans le règlement de du min
de rungis est bien à partir de 8h du
matin et les mecs ils s'en vont acheter
alors si tous les grands les gros
supermarché est tous les gros cours des
halles ou qu'ils ont des employés alors
c'est pareil les pauvres pignoufs qui
arrive à une heure et on n'a plus rien
et on a les résidus alors c'est pas
normal non plus
vous achetez combien de quantités de
légumes par exemple je sais pas on
achète par dizaines de tonnes pour vous
donner un exemple par exemple
nous achetons 35 à 40 tonnes de pommes
de terre par semaine nous achetons une
tonne 6 à 2 tonnes de pamplemousse et
puis ainsi de suite oui les attend un
canton attend mon mari pourquoi mais
vous ici madame parce que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de choix
c'est surtout pour le choix pas parce
que j'étais sous la main je suis venu
changer des pneus puis en même temps je
fais mon marché pro bowl et puis je fais
le plein puis tout un peuple est
tranquille pour quatre singes ou
d'acheminer coûte que 15 jours après je
trouve ça très pratique pour la tout
sous la main pour le temps c'est assez
facile
ben c'est à dire pour moi que j'ai
réussi c'est parce qu'on va beaucoup
plus vite que dans les autres commerces
à l'hypermarché offre une prestation de
services à l'aménageur qui travaillent
le marché offre une forme de dilettante
la ménagère qui a le temps d'y aller je
crois que c'est là la grosse différence
et au point de vue qualité bien je pense
que la qualité est exactement la même la
présentation est différente puisque nous
offrant une prestation de service qui
est un libre service et à dire que la
ménagère se sert directement n'a pas
faire peser sa marchandise et passe
directement aux caisses ont choisi soi
même parce que on vous passe devant vous
au point
il n'est pas emballé ça c'est le côté un
peu embêtant des supermarchés que tout
soit emballé comme ça le légume est il
fou il faut que ce soit à l'air il faut
que ce soit je pendrai supermarché s'est
enveloppé c'est non ça me plaît pas on
peut pas quand même voir la marchandise
parce qu'elle est sous emballage et tout
ça tandis que la halle à marchandises
est allé on peut quand même toucher un
peu ça tripote pas du tout en disco la
save à tripoter s'est renfermé c'est
quand même plus grand que soi marchands
ambulants et ce qui est des légumes qui
ne cède pas ou très très peu
oui à des légumes qu'ils ont
a disparu mais enfin qui ont diminué de
volume par exemple l'épinard le chou de
bruxelles sont les légumes qu'ils ont
une trop de préparation pour la ménagère
les ménagères n'achète plus mais c'est
achètent moins d'avoir peut-être pour
deux raisons parce qu'elle travaille
comme moins de temps et puis dans
l'autre côté c'est très long à préparer
ait pas très long si on accorde pas
beaucoup de temps à la cuisine est ce
que vous croyez qu'il aura vraiment une
disparition de ces légumes là il y aura
peut-être pas une disparition dans la
consommation mais une disparition dans
la distribution la dissolution ne se
fera plus par
or les mots de l'est mode actuelle
c'est-à-dire par les halles ça se fera
par les surgelés par les conserves parce
que là la ménagère est très intéressé à
trouver de temps en temps un article qui
est qu'ils ne se trouvent pas au marché
la publicité vous a pas fait venir ici
pas du tout soit bien ici c'est parce
qu'on sait pourquoi
ça fait deux ans que je viens non c'est
par la publicité
c'est là disons que c'est pratique comme
c'est pratique jean plis mon chariot et
puis ça me donne des idées quoi c'est
surtout quand je vais dans un magasin je
sais pas on n'est pas trop quoi acheter
tandis que là je vois tout ce qui est un
petit peu tenté quoi j'avoue que c'est
un petit peu tentés eh ben je dis que
c'est dans la tête qui on y va c'est
automatique
c'est ça le rend la publicité ça est là
vous achetez un peu ça vous gave dans la
tête et puis ça se déroule tout seul
après c'est le magnétophone
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas qu'il y a
une certaine froideur dans les
supermarchés non je ne pense pas c'est
pas du tout la même forme de marché que
le marché traditionnel mais c'est un
marché qui offre à la ménagère un étal
très important des formes de qualité
différente et je pense que elle gagne du
temps parce que elle a besoin de ce
temps là les personnels un conseil donc
personne ne l'a conseil
3 qu'un jour nous arriverons à voir une
prestation de service c'est-à-dire que
nous reprendrons en main la clientèle
comme elle est prise en main sur
l'hypermarché et que nous aurons des
auteurs qui ne s'occuperont que des
clients qui les guideront qui les
conseilleront mais je crois que c'est
pour l'hypermarché de demain c'est une
variable en 2000 mais vous avez senti
donc c'était tellement certainement mais
ça ne dérange pas ça non j'ai à vous
dire on n'est pas tous pareils
je crois que si effectivement il ya le
contact et ce contact important surtout
dans le ciel que nous vivons
actuellement qui fait qu'à ménagères est
entouré connu appelé par son nom à qui
on demande des nouvelles de son dernier
bambins qui est née elle ne trouvera pas
ça chez nous que c'est un fait mais elle
trouvera certainement de prestation de
service équivalente au point de vue
marchandises au point de vue prix et au
point de vue qualité de la marchandise
qu'elle achète chez nous et vous n'aimez
pas l'ambiance des marchés ambulants
pour ya trop de monde faut faire trop là
que tu y as pas toujours ce qu'on ne
trouve pas toujours ce qu'on veut et au
point de vue contact humain
ayala pape oui oui oui oui j'aimerais le
contact humain oui
lippert et ils ont le service qu'il rend
le marché est le côté disons agréable
pour l'aménageur de pouvoir discuter ou
même de pouvoir rencontrer du monde
oui j'aime le marché pense que ça
apporte de chaleureux le côté chaleureux
qu'on n'a pas dans les supermarchés
[Musique]
monsieur armand vous êtes le président
des marchands forains de versailles oui
madame
qu'est ce que vous vendez des chaussures
vous venez chaque semaine trois fois par
semaine le mardi le mercredi le vendredi
et aujourd'hui vous avez pas dû faire
grand chose
aujourd'hui les intempéries nous
permettent pas de travailler c'est une
catastrophe
d'ailleurs comme beaucoup de fois
malheureusement nous avons souvent de la
pluie et je voudrais que même les
percepteurs et les contrôleurs puissent
comprendre ce problème là quand on leur
apporte nos forfaits et sur beaucoup de
marchés nous avons affaire à des
concessionnaires qui prennent un prix
exorbitant sur les places
ensuite il ya un certain raquette qui
est fait par les placiers pour payer les
places et ça devient vraiment très très
onéreux
[Musique]
non mais
c'est vous qui faites vos chaussures
oui mais tout ce qui à la salle étalages
qu'est ce que je vois en décide toujours
moi qui fais et quand est ce que vous
faites ça va dans la semaine toute la
journée toute la journée oui vous fait
combien de marché je fais seulement ici
cette zone du dimanche et vous faites
aussi des chaussures sur mesure
oui mais c'est rare à notre époque tu
vas y en a quelques-uns on gagnait bien
notre vie maintenant ça devient très dur
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de charges à
payer parce que nous avons exactement
les mêmes charges que les autres
magasins que que n'importe quel
commerçant mais malheureusement nous
sommes vraiment les parents pauvres des
commerçants à l'époque où vraiment où
les tous les gens recherchent un petit
peu la nature ou même nos dirigeants
parlent de la qualité de la vie je crois
que les marchés sont vraiment quelque
chose d'important dans l'économie
actuelle pouvait m'expliquer pourquoi
ben c'est à dire que beaucoup de gens
aiment quand même sortir fouillé c'est
un folklore il ya une certaine animation
il ya des couleurs est une grande
surface bouffantes or il nous faut
encore pour une bonne raison c'est
qu'ils ont un secteur de publicité très
développée que nous malheureusement avec
les budgets syndicaux que nous avons
c'est insignifiant et à chaque fois on
n'entend jamais parler des marchés
monsieur legrand vous êtes marche en
forêt combien de temps ça fait quatorze
mois maintenant madame vous aimez votre
métier oui bon je le ferai pas je pense
quoi pourquoi lire et vous pour la
simple raison que c'est un des seuls
métiers qui me permet de rester de
garder encore une certaine indépendance
donnant rien de voir si vous voulez un
patron et ne pas non plus avoir de
personnel à réagir et avoir décidé les
soucis de ce côté là
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
le
pour tous
[Musique]
dumont
tous
[Musique]
après la voilà
et réducteur ouais ouais
monsieur cible ou pourvoir dans les bras
de votre mère oui je sais la photo
privée mais c'était ma mère qui faisait
le commerce
mon père m'a mon frère et ma soeur
qu'est ce qu'ils vendaient de la merci
d'un peu de tout et comment ça se
passait y ait pas de voiture à cette
époque là si j'avais une voiture une
voiture et un cheval ah oui j'ai pas
d'auto alors c'est avant tout changer oh
oui oh oui oh oui mais moi j'ai jamais
eue d'auto hannon et perdu ma jument
1960 et j'avais c'était fini a répété
combien de temps depuis que j'ai je suis
venu au monde quoi c'est qu'elle doit
débuter dans le métier
j'ai placé pour un travail qui attire
exact énormément les jeunes des petits
marchands se sont éliminés plus et c'est
dû à quoi
je suppose que les jeunes ne veulent
plus faire ce travail
pourquoi malgré tout très dure dans le
temps il fallait quinze ans si vous
voulez pour avoir une place sur un
marché maintenant nous avons des places
libres
comment est ce que vous expliquez cela
on explique ça parle je pense le surtout
le
l'augmentation des charges qui ont
grelet tous ces gens n'est ce pas j
d'affaires battant pour agissent leaf
raison pour plus important vol dans le
temps puis les gens s'entraînent en
boutique et puis alors il ya foule
il faut le dire il ya des grandes
surfaces qui nous qui nous font souffrir
il faut lutter elle avoue regretter pas
les marchés comme autrefois ben c'était
disons c'était une autre période s'est
passé ça s'est passé c'est maintenant 6
et 10 6 le supermarché où là il est là
c'est le marché aussi ça mais voilà le
menhir mars et mai oui pourquoi
mais parce que je trouve du choix c'est
surtout alors pour l'ambiance d'un
village plus plus pour ça que pour pour
faire des affaires
le poisson les légumes et les fruits
c'est le marché qu'est ce que vous aimez
dans le marché l'animation et puis
ce à quoi le contact quand on peut
discuter avec des vents de 10,5
oui je choisis mes marchand et surtout
surtout ici c'est très bien
un mur de huy voyez les superbes avait
un coeur voilà
et chez vous ça va glisser tudor l'armée
[Musique]
le relais avec je cherche mes papiers de
42,6
aujourd'hui sa vague informe sur le
marché ont recommencé à jouer chez nous
le les histoires de temps hélas capoue
est mauvais on a moins de monde c'est
quoi pour vous le marché a chuté tout
savez j'ai arrêté en 63 parce que je
pouvais plus ça me faisait de 67 ans
puis j'étais plus tout seul c'était
toute votre vie
ah j'étais toute ma vie ça ne peut pas
savez vous répondent demander autre
chose de faire autre chose n'importe
quoi je conçois le marché comme un grand
hall où les gens puissent circuler d'un
étal à l'autre et avec l'animation qu'il
ya cet intérêt permanent parce que
vraiment déjà nos marchés sont la
qualité de la vie parle par le bagout de
nos camelot par tout le folklore que
nous pouvons apporter
[Musique]